(soft ambient music)
- Devils Tower is an
amazingly special place.
It's just up and out of the prairie, like,
what happened here?
There's something inexplicable,
but happily undeniable
about the power of Devils Tower.
(bouncy orchestral violin music)
I'm Frank Sanders, and I am professional
rock climbing guide.
I'm not sure how I got here,
but the shoe really fits.
I've been climbing since I was 15,
so I guess I've been climbing 50 years.
I'm 65 years old, still doin' it.
The first time I saw the
Devils Tower up real and close
was June of 1972, and that night
the sky was full of lightning.
The flashes, the booms,
illuminated the tower.
It was intimidating, sure.
That's why I came all that
way, to be intimidated.
I have somewhere around
2,000 ascents of the tower.
The joy in guiding is to
be along when somebody else
hits that experience,
and you get to share it.
It's fantastic.
The rock wants to be climbed,
and if you look at the rock,
the rock will show you
right where to touch
and how hard to touch.
Right on, partner.
The tower is a every-ready partner.
I don't wanna sound too trippy here,
but you touch it, it touches you.
(bouncy clapping music)
Gettin' to the top of the
tower is both a physical
and an emotional, spiritual journey.
Looks like I can't do it,
but then in your heart
you believe you can.
To be on top, to be honest with
you, for me, is a let down.
We've run outta rock to climb.
Right now, Devils Tower,
if I had to pick one word,
is home for me; I'm happy.
(lively chiming)